tout le monde en a parlé c'était le buzz
des vacances vous avez qu'on a changé
d'année on est passé de 2019 en 2020 on
est allé dont vers l'avenir
oui et pendant ce temps là il y avait
des gens qui changent et d'année mais
pour aller vers le passé sadirac
pratiquer un genre d'humour qui était
peut-être tolérer tolérable ya 50 ans
mais qui ne l'est plus propose de
regarder en quoi ça consiste ensuite en
commente c'est une carte c'est une
catastrophe
franchement c'est mais c'est affligeant
je les ai vus plusieurs fois donc
c'était bon je veux dire pour le premier
set et 1er janvier
le compte mais non c'est pas rasiste a
besoin mais non c'est pas si tu as
publié sur instagram des extraits d'une
soirée jacques faith avec des employés
d'une grande marque de sous-vêtements
français on y voit un participants
déguisés en singes et les autres avec la
peau s'est teintée en noir en imitant
l'accent africain alors ça a énormément
chez quick choqué bien sûr c'est normal
mais je vous dis moi je je me suis sais
c'est pas possible c'est assez
incroyable regarder les yeux sans bon
sens la communauté alors évidemment
c'est une évidence mais aucun incident
n'a élèves africains
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors ça je disais aux équipes visées
ont fait vite là dessus parce que pour
moi c'est affligeant
voilà j'adore ça ne c'est pas drôle du
tout on ne comprend pas je comprend pas
le projet voilà c'est la bêtise dans
toute sa splendeur
il n'y a rien d'autre à dire il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont été extrêmement
choqués je vous le dis et voilà donc je
leur fais d'une énorme bisou pour ce
soir à eux et c'est vraiment une énorme
bêtise
voilà franchement géraldine c'est une
amitié évidemment affreux ignoble mais
le truc c'est qu'il faut faire de la
pédagogie
pourquoi c'est scandaleux est ce qu'au
19e siècle avait les mistral chaud et je
pense que c'est important que les jeunes
ne sachent en fait aux états unis
y'avait l'esclavagé il y avait des
allures français enfin des acteurs
blancs pardon keith grimé en noir et qui
singe et match aller les noirs en se
faisant passer pour des gens ignorants
stupide fainéant que c'était juste
immonde et juste il faisait de la danse
il faisait de la musique évidemment
c'était dans l'est dans les régions
suprémacistes et raciste et donc
évidemment que c'est insupportable mais
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut
carrément interdire le blackface parce
que c'est pas pénal alors il ya une
lumière dans 60 civils soumissionner
voulais je voulais montrer six matches
on avait un couple de restaurateurs
déclenché aussi une vive polémique sur
les réseaux sociaux ils ont appelé une
crête banane chocolat
la crêpe mamadou alors c'est pas une
vanne au lit ça aussi ça a énormément
choqué les eaux là c'était sur 66
minutes s'est passé hier sur m6 valiant
banque rep une simple banal conflit
et du nutella dessus elle s'appelle la
mamadou la fameuses crêpes mamadou le
prénom mamadou pour une craie banane
nutella une appellation insultante à
connotation raciste qui a provoqué un
tollé sur la toile
stéphane et laura sont submergés par les
messages d'insultés des messages mais
aussi des coups de téléphone anonymes en
plein service et même des menaces de
mort pour éteindre l'incendié
le couple a retiré la crête mamadou de
son site internet
mais pas de la carte du restaurant ça
aussi c'est incroyable qu'on prend pas
mal on comprend pas ce genre de bananes